un homme condamné à 18 mois de prison
pour avoir félicité le terroriste d'aras
et menacé cya je vous jure que c'est
vrai je ne le savais même pas je l'ai
appris là 17h50 juste avant de de faire
l'émission il a été interpellé il y a 3
jours et condamné hier beaucoup de
personnalités ont été menacé avec leur
prise de position leur post sur les
réseaux sociaux regardez ce qui s'est
passé je le découvre avec vous et Bruno
pomard ancien policier du raid ma de
belle fou sera avec nous et je crois
qu'il a eu des copaines du
SPIP la semaine dernière un terrible
attentat a eu lieu dans un lycée à aras
le bilan est lourd un mort et deux
personnes grièvement blessées et alors
que le meurtre du professeur a ému la
France entière un homme a de son côté
décidé dans la foulée de féliciter
l'auteur de l'attentat sur les réseaux
sociaux dans l'une de ses vidéos le
jeune homme profère aussi des menaces
contre Cyril hanuna et le met en garde
grâce à un signalement l'homme qui
affirmait vouloir simplement faire le
buzz a pu être interpellé et a été
condamné à 18 mois de prison
ferme mais alors euh donc les gars donc
voilà donc la vidéo est-ce qu'on peut me
dire ce qu'il avait dit le gars voilà al
il a dit bravo je voulais féliciter pour
l'attaque au couteau ce qu'il a dit
voilà tout le mal que vous avez fait à
la Palestine vous allez payer je le jure
vous allez payer c'est que le début
monsieur Hanouna petit coufard fais très
attention à ce que tu fais et toute la
République fait très attention bande de
coufard alors un coufard c'est un mot en
arabe qui désigne un M crayant un
infidèle voilà et c'est vrai que moi je
savais même pas j'étais même pas au
courant pu je vois pas ce que je viens
faire dans cette histoire moi je suis
dans toutes les sauces moi chaque fois
qu' y a un truc non mais c'est où moi
donc je voilà Bruno c'est un truc de fou
cette histoire raconte-nous je savais
même pas ça va par contre tu pars à la
chasse direct
après non mais c'est vra y a de la perd
dans le
quartier phot de mon accent vas-y non
mais alors vas-y alors non mais c'est
quoi cette histoire est folle non en
même temps c'est c'est courageux de
revenir sur le plateau ce soir avec les
menaces que tu reçois même non mais
c'est V non mais c'est vrai que moi je
je regarde même pas tu sais non mais
c'est c'est le problème de la société
actuelle où on a uneisation extrême de
tous ces tarés qui balancent des des
posts sur les réseaux sociaux qui font
des déclarations à à tour de bras pour
faire du buzz hein c'est pour faire du
buzz hein quand il s'attaque à toi il
fait du buzz il sait qu'on va en parler
lapr t'entends pas à mon avis tu as dû
tu as dû toucher avec un animal mort
euh en arrivant ici a dû toucher le
micro avec une perdie ou un truc comme
ça donc dis-nous ce que tu disais ouais
non je te disais ce qu'on voit sur les
réseaux sociaux tout ce qui alimente
cette haine et qui qui alimente
l'apologie du du terrorisme c'est c'est
un élément évident de nos jours et et je
crois qu'il faut le sanctionner
gravement là le gars a pris 18 mois
ferme il aurait pu prendre jusqu'à 5 ans
donc 18 mois ferme il peut prendre une
très grosse amende je pense que c'est le
mieux je je vous entendais tout à
l'heure parler la sanction à valeur
d'exemple même avec les jeunes et
l'affaire qu'on a vu dans les dans les
collèges je crois qu'il faut sanctionner
mais que ça soit réalisé je vais vous
dire un truc je suis parti en
Ouzbékistan ah ouais on se perd un peu
mais invité par la police là-bas et je
discutis avec la police qui me dit en
France vous êtes vachement sympa en
terme de sanctions et cetera là-bas
l'oubékistan on sort de l'ancienne
Russie qu'est-ce qui se passe là-bas
moindre délit tu prends 15 jours fermes
ah ouais le petit délit 15 jours ferme
ça veut dire que sur les des cas comme
ça tu prends un maximum donc je pense
qu'à un moment donné compte tenu de la
situation de ce qui se passe en
Palestine à Gaza et en Israël il faut
être intransigent je pense que le
gouvernement et Darman a raison de taper
dur sur ce type d'individu voilà il va
prendre 18 mois ferme et ça va lui faire
du bien l'affaire était sérieuse parce
que c'était sur TikTok donc quand c'est
sur une plateforme ça passe à 7 ans donc
il risquait 7 ans de prison donc il
était poursuivi pour apologie d'un acte
terroriste et menace de crime contre les
personnes c'està-dire vous Cyril donc
c'était vraiment sérieux ouais alors il
a été il a fait ses vidéos il a été
signalé sur la fameuse plateforme Faros
vous savez la plateforme qui permet de
dire il y a quelqu'un a fait ça et
cetera il a été interpellé il a dit je
voulais simplement faire du buzz mais on
l'a pas cru et c'est quelqu'un qui avait
déjà été condamné mais simplement si je
puis dire pour des vols et des des
violences notamment violence conjugale
c'est terrible mais c'est moins fort que
ça et donc là la sanction est quand même
exemplaire il aura un suivi de 2 ans en
plus ensuite donc voilà il y a une
volonté de durcir les condamnations en
ce moment très nette et et ce que dit
euh ce qui dit Gill est important Faros
Faros c'est une plateforme hein qui qui
peut intercepter tout pardon ça
appartient à au ministère de de
l'Intérieur évidemment he c'est la DCPJ
euh c'est un service qui est important
qu' faudrait même renforcer il y a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de de
fonctionnaires vous êtes en train de de
rigoler tous les deux je je sais
pourquoi pas du tout non c'est la DCPJ
qui a mis son CPG ouais le pho c'est
très important parce qu' il capte tout
ce qui se passe ils font 4 à 500
signalement par jour fa savoir far
ensuite ça passe en procédure judiciire
et CETA et ensite il y a fermeture
Portugal des cont non c'est important de
de le signaler c'est des services qui
sont importants pour pour essayer de
juguler cette problématique qui est
l'apologie du terrorisme pardonnez-moi
ça allit très vite bah oui ou c'est
bien é hyper
expé il voulait faire du buz il a réussi
il va prendre mois et puis voilà il
avait quand même fait ses vidéos avec un
masque de Ben Laden ouand pas je l'ai
appris là avant d'arriver qui qui a reçu
des menaces je sais que géraline Valérie
beaucoup de menacesoup de messages pas
très sympa pas très cool oui bah des
après voilà on en a tous tout le temps
là particulièrement
évidemment voilà je je camarade ch tu en
as reçu aussi beaucoup tuas reçu
beaucoup d'insultes tu en as toi tu vas
arrêter d'ouvrir ta gueule on t'a dit tu
en as pas marre de bouffer les couilles
à
Hanouna questionant je pas c'est
original non mais cela dit pardon
pardonnez-moi mais beaucoup question de
ça aussi effectivement c'estàd que notre
prise de parole aujourd'hui par rapport
à ce qu'on fit majeur et on va pas se
plaindre si on a des mauvais messages au
vu de tout ce qui se passe dans le monde
aujourd'hui et justuse qui atroce
exement mais il est beaucoup question de
en fait on n'a pas une parole libre ce
qu'on dit c'est par rapport à vous parce
que vous êtes juif et parce que vous
détenez il y a donc il y a tous les tous
les relan justement antisémites l'argent
le pouvoir les médias la prise de parole
totalement manipulé tout ça donc c'est
voilà je dire on même et sachez-le et
Jacques peut le dire et les autes aussi
on fait même pas de brief avant
l'émission il disent exactement ce
qu'ils veulent et Gilles Verdes vous le
prouve bien parce que surtout les sujets
c'est vrai que voil tu sais cyil ces
problèmes de de de menace que vous avez
les gens connus et cetera c'est infernal
pour les services de police parce qu'il
faut savoir que le service de la
protection le fameux SDLP ils sont à
1300 effectifs c'està-dire 1300
policiers qui sont dédiés à assurer non
seulement la sécurité des membres du
gouvernement c'est des grosses sécurités
de top niveau hein et ensuite bah des
gens comme vous parfois on peut pouvez
avoir un policier qui est détaché
rarement parce que généralement il faut
comment dire s'attarder sur les sociétés
de sécurité privée mais généralement ce
service est saturé de demande évidemment
de protection cont tenu de la menace qui
qui s'appelle Camil un pote à moi qui me
dit aussi tous les jours je reçois des
menaces de mort de sympathisant
israéliens qui me menace de mort
également alors qu' pas il me dit voilà
c'est c'est des deux côtés c'est vrai
que c'est ça qui est grave c'est ça qui
est affreux parce que en plus il y a
aucune guerre entre entre nous voilà
c'est vraiment en plus ici on a un
message de paix en plus tous les soirs
bien au contraire et c'est vrai que
c'est ça qui est fou parce que même
quand vous avez un message de paix et
quoi qu'on dise d'apaisement en fait et
ben vous faites vous faites fracasser
sur les réaux on a eu ici je crois le
message de paix de le plus gros message
de paix de toutes les émissions et voilà
tous les TKS et c'est vrai que c'est
vous qui qui prenez et qui vous faites
voilà secouer Jacques toi toi c'est vrai
que c'est la première fois que tu as des
menaces comme ça oui
euh oui c'est j'ai j'ai quelqu'un m'a
croisé dans les rues pas tellement loin
d'ici il m'a dit enfin voilà il m'a
apostrophé en disant fais gaffe à ce que
tu dis sur la Palestine avec un ton très
menaçant mais bon je pense que ce que
j'ai vécu vous l'avez tous vécu donc on
est tous à peu près dans le même je
savais pas ça ouais ouais non mais bon
après faut pas bien sûr voilà bon et
après j'ai reçu un certain nombre de
messages comme ça les deux ou trois
premiers ils étaient très très durs euh
vraiment menaçants je les ai effacés
j'ai appris qu'il fallait pas les
effacer donc voilà donc après je les
efface plus les autres ils sont plus
voilà c'est c'est c'est des messages je
considère que c'est de l'insulte là
voilà celui-là on sait voilà après j'en
ai eu un ou deux du genre on saitù on
sait où tu es tes propos sont à gerbés
voilà le problème c'est que depuis le
début on on essaie effectivement d'avoir
ce message de paix mais surtout de de
dissocier le Hamas du sort des
Palestiniens et je pense que ça il faut
que c'est quand je dis il faut qu'il y
ait des cours d'histoire pour les gamins
et cetera et cetera je suis pas sûr
qu'une partie de la population est
vraiment intégrer ça je ne sais pas quel
est si tu veux l'environnement dans
lequel ces gens vivent nous